three years ago we launched the Great
American comeback right tonight I stand
before you to share the incredible
results
I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm running for
president to lead our Great American
comeback
you go back to Reagan's State of the
Union speech in I believe it's 86 and
there it was that the uh in that
particular speech Reagan bragged about
37 straight months of economic growth
and falling interest rates and he said
it's because of conservative values and
he talked about the Great American
comeback so Trump didn't invent it if
you want to argue that anybody has like
a claim to these phrases it would be
Reagan also important Trump didn't make
up make America great again Reagan used
a slightly different version of it back
in 1980 where he said let's make America
great again